how how would a third fight with you
when anthony joshua be different
i think it would be a lot different
because you've seen what i could do and
with me being out of shape me being
almost 300 pounds
and me being in shape me being ready
like just how i was in my first fight
against him i think
i would win man that for sure i would
feel that i would win i'm learning a lot
of stuff right there with eddie and
canelo so i think
i think my style will be a little bit
different than the first time
what advice would you have for that mike
going into the third fight with somebody
would you think would be the difference
in that fight well i think the jab his
jab
basically put him in position for
everything i think he gets just keep
using the jab putting it in the face two
or three times
follow with the right left you know well
without the jab you can't
really throw no combination especially
with these big guys we have to throw the
jabs to get in there you know yeah yeah
because you're you're considered
a lot like you don't know if you don't
throw a jab he could see everything
coming
you see the hooks you can see everything
coming you got blind keep
doing that behind them yeah but he's a
lot because
you're what six six foot eight i mean
six one
six one yeah but for like the
heavyweights with the tyson
you know i mean these dudes are what six
seven dude but sometimes that's
that could be a disadvantage yeah
for me i liked fighting taller fighters
because for some reason it's
easier for me to get in there um see the
punches he saw what happened in the
first fight when he fought joshua see
joshua was
for real cautious the second fight he
gets out pointed him tap tap boom
but i was too big and without the
condition to
cut the rings to to follow him you know
not to follow him but to cut the reins
and to throw the combinations right
there i was just doing one punch
two punch and there's some punches that
would connect them and like wobble him
but
i feel i didn't have the stamina to
continue to keep throwing or
i don't know but things happen but you
guys throw
they were good they kept them from
throwing back at you yeah and look good
good combination sets you got to keep
working because i did felt the rust from
being like almost two years off but like
how you're saying stop beating yourself
up that was
beautiful man two years that was
[Music]
beautiful